members of the Rob core myself and
comics Torian will be at New York Comic
Con this year we are hosting a panel on
Friday October 6 from 7:45 p.m. to 8:45
p.m. last time we did a panel we had 400
people show up no idea if we're gonna
get those same numbers this time because
we're at night but in order to lure um I
will have Rob core rings yes I have
ordered 15 size 12 rings 15 size 9 rings
and 15 size 10 rings those will be given
away at the actual con like at the panel
so hopefully hopefully we'll have enough
I have no idea I mean we ordered
basically 45 no idea if we'll actually
have that many people show up I don't
know never really hosted a panel at like
8 o'clock at night which is kind of a
weird thing but I digress on to the
video so Batman red death is really
really really cool for a couple of
reasons the idea of Batman being like an
evil version of the flash is cool but
it's also it seems like some of the
rules that DC's creating when it comes
to these various you know alternate
universes is really what this is now
it's very cloak-and-dagger in terms of
how this whole concept exists right
because it's not fully fleshed out I
mean we're still learning about Dark
Knight's metal and presumably this will
have lasting effects that will go
forward into DC rebirth the indication
from me is that this is basically in
opposite multiverse in the Simpson and
DC comics you've got the multiverse
right and it's just 52 earths that's it
I mean you've got like gods and you've
got realms and spheres and different
things like that
but there's only 52 earths that exist
out there and the multiverse now there's
also the idea that there's like multiple
multiverses but we don't need to get
into that that's more of like an omni
verse than anything else but that it
within the new 52 branding so to speak
there's only 52 earths then there's the
opposite side you know there is two
sides of the same coin basically heads
is all the good earths where Batman
became great Lantern different things
like that the bottom side is 52
different earths where everything that
can go wrong has gone wrong
now this is kind of a crazy scenario
because what this initially does is it
actually just sort of picks up with
Batman chasing after Barry Allen and
kind of cool here because again this
hits hole into the whole like
intelligence of Bruce Wayne with enough
prep time he can do anything but you
also have to remember this is more of an
ally as opposed to like a straight-up
enemy not only that Batman is actually
using a lot of the villains of the
various rogues that exist out there but
so are so some was flash like barium is
literally filling like mirror master
tricks and so on and so forth but this
also has a very dark not return to esque
feel to it
and the reason why I say that is that
before Batman was outselling Superman he
was just a guy whose book was on the
verge of cancellation Frank Miller wrote
the Dark Knight Returns and that's why
it is that Batman fought Superman for
the very first time and they've been
fighting ever since I mean they fight
all the time now I mean you get all
these stories where they battle one
another because people really really
love it now anything in excess is never
a good thing but you know it is cool to
see those conflicts take place however
Dark Knight Returns gave us this kind of
dystopian future where like the entire
bat family was gone Bruce Wayne had
basically just sort of retired there was
really no one defending Gotham and it
just kind of run amuck eventually he
came out every time and went back to
saving Gotham fought Superman beat him
there are a lot of other things that
we're going on with regards to that
story but this is much the same way and
the reason for this is because within
this universe the entire bat family is
basically dead
Batgirl Dick Grayson Damian Wayne Jason
Todd Tim Drake they're all gone
and now we don't know who killed him we
don't know what it was that killed him
we're just kind of left to presume from
the wording of Batman that they were
quote-unquote consumed by Gotham I know
that really means is they were probably
just killed by miscellaneous villains
over the course of however long you know
Jason Taub was probably killed by the
Joker just like the way he was in the
original death of the family story Tim
Tim Drake Barbara Gordon different
things like that they just fell
somewhere along the line and what this
is done is it's put Batman in this
mindset where he almost seems totally
irrational and that's why I say this is
kind of like the opposite of the way the
multiverse is supposed to be because
usually Batman is like the most
level-headed Batman is really like the
least emotional and the most logical
when everybody else was running around
fighting and beating things up
Batman's doing the same thing but he's
calculating all the variables he's
calculating all the constants all the
odds what do we need to do in order
to assure you know to ensure that we
come out on this this conflict as
opposed to just hoping we do by Superman
and Wonder Woman strength and speed and
so on
with this scenario he is logical but
he's basically insane the idea here is
that with the Speed Force Barry Allen
can basically use its power to run back
and forth through time and the idea of
Bruce Wayne is that he wants to
essentially steal the Speed Force power
or use it to go back in time and save
people's lives and that's why things get
kind of crazy because what we learned
with flashpoint is that there's always
consequences right with a flashpoint
story the Barry Allen went back in time
and saved his mom from being killed by
you know reverse-flash eobard thawne the
result is that he spawned the flashpoint
universe where Bruce Wayne died instead
of Thomas and Martha Wayne
Thomas Wayne became Batman Martha Wayne
became the Joker
you know the Atlanteans and the Amazons
were at war with one another Aquaman and
Wonder Woman were trying to kill each
other
Superman had never been discovered by
the Kent's he crash-landed on earth he
was immediately grabbed by the
government and stuck in a bunker
underground I mean there were all these
massive changes that went on and they
were huge in terms of how they unfolded
so Barry Allen said okay this is totally
wrong if he goes back in time he lets
his mom die and then he wakes up in a
different universe in the new 52 you can
never go back to the way things used to
be that no matter what change you make
it changes things forever and Barry
Allen has learned that lesson time and
time again either by watching others do
it or by doing it himself and so in this
scenario the lot of Duty spills to Bruce
Wayne is if you go back in time and you
save the life of Barbara Gordon and Dick
Grayson and Jason Todd and Tim Drake and
Damian Wayne there's no telling what the
universe will be like it could be that
you save their lives but in that moment
when you were not there for them or
whatever the case may be they just
develop this insane hatred for you and
the result is that you basically show up
in a universe where you're supposed to
be dead because they killed you and
they've basically taken over the world
they killed all the superheroes any
number of things can happen but it's the
fact that you don't know what the
outcome will be that makes time travel
so dangerous now the other half of this
is the way the Speed Force works because
it's kind of a funny scenario if
we go back and we read flash born to run
I think it was where for the flash Wally
West outran the universe he ran from the
edge of the universe all the way to
Earth and like almost a split second one
of the things that we're told is that
the Speed Force is infinite there's no
limit to the Speed Force but if we go
and reread Geoff Johns flash rebirth
we're told the Speed Force is finite
that only so many speedsters can tap
into the Speed Force if you read
flashpoint it's the exact same thing you
know I'm sorry Barry Allen needs to
travel back into the past but he can't
because yeah Bart Thawne is using the
Speed Force and because they're both
using it at the same time there's not
enough energy for Barry Allen to travel
back into the past so it depends on what
rider it is that we're talking about but
regardless of how the Speed Force is
depicted with regards to this scenario
here what we know is that only people
who have a connection to the Speed Force
can basically enter it the Speed Force
is a locked door the only people with
the keys are speedsters now this is just
like any other locked door right if you
know the person with a key you put a gun
to their back make him walk up to the
door and unlock it and that's what
Batman does here Batman literally knocks
out Barry Allen after manipulating his
speed powers you know tricking him
essentially messing with his mind and
then in turn straps him to the front of
the web of the Batmobile and races him
into the Speed Force now under normal
circumstances our initial thought would
be okay so Barry Allen enters the Speed
Force and then Batman enters and dies
that's not true remember we've seen
instances where people who are not part
of the flash family which is to say who
are not speedsters have been thrust and
locked into the Speed Force case in
point
superboy-prime we saw that during
Infinite Crisis superboy-prime was
grabbed by the speedsters he was raced
into the Speed Force Barry Allen grabbed
him and pulled him in you know and he
was basically locked there for however
long now of course he re-emerged and
then just absolutely massacred the earth
superheroes but up until that point we
had never really seen a lot of instances
where a person who was not a speedster
had been locked in the Speed Force we'd
seen it before but a superboy-prime is
the most popular example and that's why
I use that but the idea here is that
with Batman going into the Speed Force
and basically merging himself as Barry
Allen what he ends up doing is stepping
down as the Red Death and this is kind
of an interesting situation because
the implication here is that there's one
of two scenarios going on the first
scenario is that this guy Bruce Wayne is
just now an evil bad guy like he's just
a villain that's it
he's just an evil dude and there's no
way for him to come back from this the
other half of that is that Bruce Wayne
is not entirely lost now the way in
which this happens is that when he steps
out of the Speed Force and his world is
basically crashing down around him that
there's almost like this inner turmoil
right like Barry Allen speaks to Bruce
Wayne this is look you're not a bad guy
you know you can go back and you can fix
this and there's a brief moment of
hesitancy now it also seems like this
power has basically run to Bruce Wayne's
head maybe he's possibly even possessed
we don't know that for an absolute truth
all we know is this guy red death refers
to himself as Bruce Wayne so the
implication is that it is Bruce Wayne
acting of his own accord he doubts
himself a bit but it doesn't matter the
other thing here is that with this
universe basically crashing down or with
this earth basically being destroyed
what this seems to do is hit home at the
idea of rules within the multiverse when
it comes to the multiverse and DC Comics
for the most part their depiction of how
the various worlds exists has really
just kind of been free reign right like
I mean Infinite Crisis introduced like
the monitors different things like that
Final Crisis gave us the monitors again
and so on and it was this idea that the
monitors serve the purpose of making
sure that the Earth's heroes never
crossed over that earth one didn't show
up on earth QED earth two didn't show up
on her three and that was about it after
that it was whatever goes on in those
worlds goes on in those worlds just do
what you want to just make sure you know
you don't show up in somebody else's
house so it was really that the monitors
are more of like prison guards as
opposed to actually people who were
maintaining you know the house and so on
and so forth and weren't really
landlords but in this instance what this
seems to do is it hit hits home at these
finite rules things are supposed to
happen a certain way certain characters
aren't always supposed to live if they
die it quote-unquote breaks things you
know for example let's take like this
scenario with the bat family we don't
know if it was the death of the Baths
family that triggered this we don't know
if it was Bruce Wayne making the
decision to go after the flash that
triggered this all we know is that this
world is just crumbling to pieces
it's basically falling apart and the
location seems to be is because Bruce
Wayne is playing a character he's not
supposed to be he's breaking the rules
of the multiverse he's breaking the
rules of this universe now if this is
true because at this point this is just
speculation on my part it's not being
told that it's true it's just kind of my
guess but if this is true it would
change everything
because what it does is it basically
takes this whole idea of in every
universe there's a Batman in every
universe there's a Superman in every
universe is a flash as a Wonder Woman so
on and so forth
it takes that from the realm of being
well that's just kind of how things
worked out to being this is the way it
always is there's always a flash in
every universe there's always a Batman
there's you know there's always a
Justice League there's always these
superheroes and they always exist
because if they don't the world simply
just can't exist for whatever reason now
something else that ends up happening
here is that this Red Death actually
displays a power that we've never seen
before when it comes to speedsters
stealing the abilities you're stealing
the speeds of other powers or other
other characters usually it is an
extension of themselves in this sense
they have to like run up on them they
have to touch them something along those
lines you know it's not really like a
telekinetic or a telepathy thing and
this instance red death is like
accompanied by these bats which is super
cool and when he shows up in the new 52
earth these bats immediately attack like
the other you know the other new 52
Wally West and like drain him of his
Speed Force powers to the point that he
basically just grows super old and it
gets crazy because then Barry Allen
shows up of course you know this flash
from Earth zero shows up and simply says
like you are not going to face off
against my guys you know you're not
gonna attack my friends yadda yadda
yadda but before he can step in and
before he can actually fight Red Death
what we end up finding out is that his
Speed Force powers are basically beings
they're being siphoned they're being
taken away now again in the middle of
all this dr. fate grabs him and whisks
him away and that's a big deal because
with dr. fate showing up he is the
predecessor to Doctor Strange right like
doctor dr. fate existed long before dr.
strange but he's a guy that DC does not
invoke very often but when they do it
means things are about to pop off
usually whenever dr. fate intervenes it
means that the universe is moving in a
direction to where if those who are not
whisked OH
to a quote unquote safe place if that's
not actually done they'll basically die
it's essentially DC coming in and saying
the universe that the you know the prime
DC Universe is now on a collision course
dr. fate is literally running around and
grabbing these guys up because are the
only ones who are gonna be able to stave
off against the coming threat what it
also seems to indicate is that if Barry
Allen and if red red death were to
actually face one another Barry Allen
would died he would be killed now again
that's why dr. fate intervenes otherwise
he would have just waited you know and
then flash would have killed Brett death
and that would have been it and so it's
an interesting situation because again
it really hits home at this idea that
there's a much bigger picture here that
all these universes are crashing down
all these universes are ending because
things are not right with them and the
things that are not right are contextual
based on the origin stories of each
character that we'll see again a lot of
this was really mysterious we don't know
what direction things are heading in we
don't know what's gonna happen we can
just kind of look at it guess and hope
we understand what we got being said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain and make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace